foreign
good evening councilors ladies and
gentlemen and I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
before we formally start the meeting I
invite my chaplain the Reverend Johnny
Hill to lead us in prayer
thank you very much for having me here
and for your attention for these few
moments
and it's not uncommon for me to be asked
the question as to whether faith and
science are mutually exclusive
that if I hold to The evolutionary
origins of life on Earth then surely I
can't believe what I read in the Bible
particularly what's written about the
origins of human life
but for me there is no conflict you see
what we've discovered through science
has helped us to recognize that what we
read in the Bible is not true
at least in the factual sense of the
word
but rather the Mythic story of God
creating the first humans presents us
with a different kind of Truth
as Christians we believe that truth to
be the imbuing of innate worth and
dignity in every human being
the Divine image of God within each of
us
if any of you have been following the
happenings in the Church of England in
the past week or so you might wonder how
I could ever make such a pronouncement
about what we Christians believe
when it seems there's so much that we
cannot agree on
but the irrefutable truth of each human
being's worth an inherent dignity is
something on which No One Faith
tradition holds a monopoly
no doubt it's the universal truth that
underlies your desire to serve the
common good
as elected counselors
February marks lgbtq plus History Month
a time when we seek to acknowledge and
celebrate the history of sexual and
gender minorities people whose innate
worth and dignity has not always been
recognized and protected not least by
the church
on Saturday passed in the middle of
lgbtq History Month and just 12 or so
miles away from us here Brianna Jay a 16
year old transgender girl was murdered
the motive behind her killing remains
unclear but it's been reported in the
news today that Brianna had experienced
years of transphobic buddying bullying
now I am here this evening as Chris's
chaplain to bring a pause for Thought
type thing
and I'm here as a male Christian
minister
but I'm also here as an item proud
member of the LGBT community who lives
here in Trafford
so rather than offering a prayer I'm
going to ask us to observe a moment's
silence in memory of Brianna J
and urge us all to seek to serve the
residents of our Borough
and to be reminded of the irrefutable
truth of each human person's worth and
innate dignity as we pause now
I end this brief Silence with an amen
thank you
indeed thank you thank you very much
Johnny for that
most appreciated I'm sure by everybody
in the chamber
so we moved to our agenda the first item
which is apologies and I've received
apologies for absence from councilors
dagnell Lester Mirza and new can I ask
if anyone is aware of any other
apologies
so Mr Holt Council Holden
sorry
counselor bunting
councilor O'Brien
Council Andrew Western thank you are
there any other apologies
councilor Lloyd
counselor Lloyd
right thank you
voting and broadcast information we
continue with a hybrid system in the
chamber this evening for microphones and
streaming the microphones work by
pressing the bar on and off up to a
maximum of three at one time and for
voting I will ask for a show of hands
this meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee web meetings
YouTube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
this activity promotes Democratic
engagement in accordance with Section
100a brackets nine close brackets of the
Local Government Act
1972. thank you
item warm the first item is minutes and
I move that the minutes of meetings held
on the 4th and the 25th of January 2023
be taken as read and signed as a correct
record is that seconded
seconded math thank you leader all in
favor
thank you item two announcements his
majesty the king's New Year's honors may
we take this opportunity to recognize
those citizens and persons connected
with Trafford who were named in his
majesty the king's New Year's honors
list
Professor Linda Joyce Merrick of
Altrincham awarded a CBE for services to
music in higher education
professor
muhammadian of Bowden awarded an Obe for
services to Net Zero research and to
innovation
mbas were awarded to Mr Charles
Frederick Banks of urmston for services
to people with disabilities in Greater
Manchester and Northwest England Mrs
Gwyneth Bellman of hail for services to
the administration of justice and to the
community in Manchester Miss Jade
Bridget Clark of Partington for services
to netball Mrs Shelley Jane Quinton Hume
of stretford for services to the
community in stretford
Professor Charlotte and skiteral of
Altrincham for services to Pharmacy and
finally Mr Mark Smallwood was awarded
the British Empire medal for services to
the community in Greater Manchester
during covid-19
I'm sure you will join with me in
conveying this council's congratulations
for their achievements and richly
deserved recognition
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening no
thank you Matt thank you leader do the
chairs of the scrutiny committees have
anything to announce on behalf of their
committees councilor Acton
thank you mayor
um I just wanted to mention a piece of
work that we are
okay
yeah I just wanted to to mention a piece
of work that scrutiny is doing I think
many of you will will know that scrutiny
has set up a Manchester United Stadium
task and finish group
uh and I think this is the first time
that we've done something like this uh
in in this Council and councilor
Lawrence Walsh is going to chair well
his chairing uh the Tuscan finish
because it has actually started
um and I think as everyone will realize
living next to Old Trafford football
ground
um it can be a very great challenge
there are many issues and concerns that
prevent itself on Match days for the
local people who who live in the area
and it's quite a wide area it's Old
Trafford it's ghost Hill it's stretford
and we we sent out a survey asking
residents what it's like living next to
Old Trafford football stadium and this
was
um
put together really with counselor Jed
Carter and councilor Fiona holdby
and we we sent it out through through
the channels of the council
and quite frankly we've had a great
response from from the residents the
nearly
500 responses and I think
um you know in any sense that that is a
big response for quite a small area
and I think it's the highest response
since the council has been using
citizens Space Systems for these kinds
of surveys and I think that is a feat in
itself and the next meeting we will be
going through those responses and I
think counselor Walsh is a great person
to have as a because he lives in the
center of ghost Hill right next to the
stadium and he knows a lot of residents
in the area and you know I do believe
that this is the first time that we've
had that challenge around man united and
I think if anybody lives in that area
you'll understand that it is very
challenging so
um you know I will report again to this
Council to actually note the responses
and also
um you know the progress that we make in
terms of our challenge that we have in
scrutiny with the stadium in that
particular on that particular side so
thank you for your Indulgence man all
right thank you councilor Acton and I
think I saw a change of emails today
where suggests that the next meeting of
that group's next Thursday or something
is it this Thursday coming it's it's
fairly imminent right
um Council or wetton for nothing from
health school to me today thank you
thank you councilor Denise Weston
nothing from Children's Group thank you
indeed thank you
um item three
Council budget 2023 2024 the main item
this evening is the budget and I'm
proposing to conduct the business as we
have done in previous years introducing
the item councilor Ross as leader with
the portfolio for finance and governance
will have a maximum of 15 minutes to
make the initial speech and at the end
the leader of the council will have a
further maximum of 15 minutes to bring
the debate to a close on behalf of the
main opposition councilors Morgan will
have a maximum of 15 minutes and then
cancel the new grosh and cancel the
Jerome on behalf of the minority
opposition groups will each have a
maximum of 10 minutes to make their
initial speeches
before the debates is brought to a close
Council as Jerome new gross and then
councilor Miss Blackburn as leaders of
the opposition groups will each have a
further maximum of five minutes
immediately before the leader of the
council
winds up the debate therefore with those
timings set aside we will need to aim to
conclude the main debate on the budget
by 8 50 PM as we also have another
report before us this evening
further speakers on the main motion will
have a maximum length of three minutes
for speeches and can I remind you that
if necessary I may have to reduce the
time for speeches and the number of
speakers in order to complete the
business
may I also draw council's attention to
regulations that require votes on the
budget to be recorded So how members
cast their votes will be recorded in the
minutes do I have the council's consent
to proceed on this basis
thank you before Council are the
executive's recommendations for the
budget agreed at the executive meeting
earlier this evening these will be moved
by the leader of the council councilor
Ross I now invite you to open the debate
thank you Matt
this evening I'm proud to be in the
position to present this labor
administration's fifth budget since
taking control of Trafford Council in
May 2018.
this is the fourth budget I presented in
my role as excuse me as executive member
for finance and it is likely to be my
last in that position
however it is the first budget I'll be
presenting as leader and I hope that
people can continue to place trust in me
to lead an Administration delivering
future budgets on behalf of the people
of Trafford
the situation I find myself in with the
opportunity to introduce the budget and
then conclude the item has shaped my
approach to speaking this year
in this part of the evening I'll be
setting out the national and local
context and how each have impacted on
our approach to the budget this year
starting with our Revenue budget
proposals but also incorporating our
capital and asset investment strategies
our Capital program treasury management
strategy and fees and charges
in many respects a lot has changed since
I presented our last budget
this time last year we were still
observing social distancing and meeting
in a larger room the situation in
Ukraine had not escalated to the
conflict that we've seen over the last
12 months inflation had not escalated to
the highest rate in 40 years and we had
no idea that we'd be seeing a change of
prime ministers not just once but twice
a change of council leader locally was
also not on the horizon however one
constant during that time was Trafford
Labor's commitment to taking the
necessary and sometimes difficult
decisions to deliver a balanced budget
that process started in February 2022
with the establishment of the finance
and change board continued over the
under the leadership of Andrew Western
and concludes this evening as one of my
first major acts as leader
however this process isn't just about
one or two people it involves so many of
the council's officers and counselors
and at this point I'd like to put on my
record my thanks to Executive colleagues
members of the scrutiny committees and
other councilors who have engaged with
the budget process I'd also like to
express my thanks to our corporate
leadership team and most of all to
Graham Bentley and his highly
experienced Finance team
we are very fortunate in Trafford to
have such an experienced set of finance
office officers as we meet Financial
challenges year in year out and I'm
pleased to confirm that at this point
Graham in his role as section 151
officer confirms the estimates made for
the purposes of the calculation of this
budget are robust and the recommended
level of air March reserves and balances
are adequate
over the past 12 years this Council has
had to deliver over 170 million pounds
worth of savings and efficiencies
it remains a scandal that local
government has borne the brunt of
austerity measures first introduced in
at that time we were promised we'd see
an end of austerity by 2015. and that
promise rings very Hollow when presented
with a gross budget gap for this year
ahead of almost 25 million pounds
on top of this councils up and down the
country are having to respond to growth
in demand for adults and children's
social care as well as inflationary
pressures and that cumulative budget Gap
since 2010 now stands at almost 290
million pounds for Trafford
in the meantime Trafford receives the
lowest spend per head of population
across across all GM authorities and the
four lowest across all Metropolitan
boroughs
we will continue to campaign as part of
the f-20 group of lowest funded councils
for the government to introduce a
funding floor quickly to bring our core
spending power to well-resourced local
Authority levels if a funding floor were
set at 90 percent of the average core
spending power of other local
authorities Trafford would receive an
extra 5.7 million pounds in Revenue so
it is necessary that we continue that
lobbying because it would make a huge
impact to Future budgets if we managed
to achieve that
like many other authorities we have
followed the government's own
assumptions regarding an increase in
council tax this year however we
continue to have a low level of council
tax and the second lowest across greater
Manchester
if we chose not to increase our council
tax we would be required to identify
5.69 million pounds worth of additional
savings which would have a significant
implication for our Frontline Services
we also have to manage the reserves we
have very carefully and our budget
papers clearly state that any further
use of reserves Beyond those committed
is not recommended
the first report provides further
commentary on how we've closed the Gap
in our budget Revenue budget our
reserve's position and our income and
savings proposals for the year ahead
on council tax reserves and our savings
and income proposals mean that we have
now closed our initial gap of almost 25
million pounds and can present a
balanced budget this evening
and it's a revenue budget that invests
in our social care and services
safeguarding vulnerable children and
adults and supporting a sustainable care
Market
we've responded to the cost of living
crisis by continuing a policy of having
one of the most generous council tax
support schemes which will help thirteen
thousand four hundred of our residents
where 80 percent of those in receipt of
support will not have any council tax to
pay
we will also be providing free over 3.2
million pounds of support to households
in most need via our Trafford assist
scheme as well as providing ongoing
support to our community hubs labor in
Trafford will always do what we can to
support people in most need and never
has this be more necessary
we also need to do more to play our part
in response to the climate crisis which
is why I'm pleased to confirm that we're
committing to additional resource in
this area to meet the necessary
challenges set by our carbon neutral
action plan
turning to Capital I'm pleased to
confirm that our program worth almost
200 million will also support Trafford
Labor's priorities for residents across
the borough
we will continue our regeneration plans
including investments in Altrincham and
Stratford Town centers and the Civic
Quarter Master Plan
our school expansion program continues
as does investment in special
educational needs provision
we continue to support the increase in
the availability and range of suitable
housing and will invest in our Parks
green spaces and a tree planting program
we're also supporting the refurbishment
of Altrincham Leisure Center with plans
regarding Stratford Leisure Center to
come and we'll be setting out an
exciting journey to transform Sport and
Leisure opportunities in Partington
I also want to also to see more progress
with our active travel proposals this
year utilizing earmarked investment in
this area
other notable areas of programs capital
investment are 1.66 million pounds of
out for outdoor sports facility
provision
2.77 million for as part of our
decarbonization program and 1.34 million
for our parks and Open Spaces we're also
committing over 22 million pounds worth
of Highways Investments further
information regarding our Capital
program is set out in the report
the papers also contain our latest asset
investment strategy which aims to meet
our corporate priorities and supports
regeneration
the investment to date has already
provided a net benefit to the revenue
budget of almost 23 million pounds since
2018. with further forecast forecast
Revenue gained of 6 million pounds for
the next year
And I stress that we continue to adopt a
prudent approach with this strategy
this evening I'm also presenting our
latest treasury management strategy and
I'd like to draw particular attention to
the updated policy on minimum Revenue
provision in section 5.
we propose to switch from an approach of
setting aside MRP for both supported and
unsupported borrowing on an equal
installment basis to an annuity basis
where MRP provision starts low and then
rises in later years
this is similar principle to how the
principal amounts increase under a
repayment mortgage and agreeing this
policy will provide support not just to
the 2324 budget but also to this current
year-in-year budget where we've faced
additional inflationary pressures
the treasury management strategy also
provides a timely reminder of the
economic turbulence we've faced over the
last year including the profound
consequences of the disastrous minibus
budget last September
we must never forget the impact that
catastrophic set of proposals had on
households up and down the country
including here in Trafford
the budget reports provides further
information also on our fees charges
allowances for the years ahead
budget has been a very challenging one
to bridge
we continue to live in times of economic
uncertainty and National indeed Global
political instability
we're a country a Borough recovering
from a pandemic that has left many
exhausted and placed extreme pressure on
our public services and the people that
provide those Services day in Day Out
in a country where we're so often let
down by politicians on the national
stage I know we all want to do our best
and prove that not all politicians are
the same
and I believe this budget demonstrates
we are different we can make the
difficult decisions we can work together
to ensure we do our best by our
residents whilst providing the most
support we can to our Frontline services
I'm proud of the contribution so many
people have made to this budget process
and I'm confident we have done the best
we can for our residents as I move the
budget papers this evening thank you
thank you councilor Ross
um is the motion seconded
it is um and reserve the right to speak
thank you thank you
I now call upon councilor Morgan to
respond to the proposed budget on behalf
of the conservative group thank you
thank you um
um thank you very much Mr Mayor for
calling me to respond to the budget on
behalf of the conservative group
um firstly on behalf of the group I'd
like to thank Graeme Bentley and the
finance team for bringing this forward
along with all of the corporate
leadership team and heads of service who
I know will have worked incredibly hard
to pull this job together and thanks to
councilor Ross for all his work
particularly when doing two jobs I know
how that feels
um
this is an incredibly difficult time a
difficult time for everyone across the
country families businesses and local
councils are included in this
Mr Mayor some of the difficult decisions
that the executive committed to if I was
in councilor Ross's shoes I would be
also having to do
and there are good parts to this budget
we support any additional funds on our
highways though it is interesting if it
comes out in an all-out selection year
education is vital particularly for
those with extra needs and we will
continue to support plans for free
School meals for children in the school
holidays
on parking charges it's nice to see not
yet another increase in park charges for
villages and town centers this year and
I hope this new approach will continue
in future years
however there are parts of this we don't
like we remain concerned about the rate
of council tax increase
whilst this is always an option for
councils to increase it during the most
difficult time for families particularly
those who are struggling before the cost
of living squeeze we deeply regret the
council increasing its burden on
families
I'm going to recognize that the council
are continuing to support vulnerable
residents through the council tax
support but I'm sure everyone especially
counselors will recognize that no system
of support is ever perfect and people
will slip through the net this tax would
have increased by over 26 since this
Administration came to power a huge
burden on all residents particularly
families who are struggling
and residents no longer have to put up
with just the council tax bill Andy
Berman has only recently just proposed
yet another large council tax increase
taking his mayoral precept to nearly 60
increase since 2018. if I only had a
mayor like Andy Street in the West
Midlands who for a sixth year in a row
was chosen not to add a memorable
precept for residents in the West
Midlands and proves it can be done
um on spending as I've said I think
there are difficult choices and I'm not
going to pretend I if I was in the
opposite side that I will be able to
spend on every area that I would want to
upon highways whilst I have said we we
welcome any additional spending given
the dire state of the highway Network in
Trafford
um we having spoken to officers last
week we still need at least 15 million
extra a year to maintain the network so
it's still short on that so this budget
acknowledges that Robo network will
continue to get worse
um I'd also like to focus on Street
lighting
particularly the 300 000 pound saving
due to reductions in both the timing and
dimming of Street lighting I'm not going
to go back on the arguments from two
years ago that we highlighted relating
to Public Safety thankfully then
following the following council meeting
the labor executive reversed that
decision it was right to do a reversal
back then and therefore reneging on that
decision is wrong
and there are some spending which we
question 1.7 million to support a new
modernization team 150 000 on additional
members expenses
would we need to be spending as much on
on waste if this Administration hadn't
failed and its recycling rates and
despite the press releases praising a
58.8 recycling rate it's still behind
where we were six years ago at 61.3 and
this Administration has seen Trafford
slip down the league tables and
recycling year in year out
however the area I want to focus for the
rest of my speech on the use of Reserves
as stated in 1.8.4 we are proposing to
use 40 of available earmarked reserves
to balance this year's budget
it states this is not sustainable going
forward and does reduce budget
resilience for the future
section 1.5.2 highlight highlights the
financial uncertainty over the coming
years and 1.6.1 highlights the limited
scope of future savings
1.8.2 States quoting we Face serious
concerns in achieving a sustainable
budget position Beyond next year
when doing any budget you need to plan
not just for the current and but you
also need to think about the future
I really have doubts that the budget
puts the traffic on the foundations
needed for the future
given the risks in the property Market
particularly Our Town centers relating
to retail there's a real risk on the
valuation of our property portfolio and
with Putin's ongoing atrocious invasion
of Ukraine nothing is guaranteed
in conclusion Mr Mayor we have
significant reservations on the
financial footing this budget puts the
borough for the future and the
conservative group will not be
supporting it this evening thank you
thank you councilor Morgan before we
continue can I just ask those people who
have laptops which are actually giving
us a musical interlude
to actually reduce the volume I think
that probably actually would mean that
they will not continue to give us those
noises I think find it particularly
distracting and I think it is solely
from laptops Whoever has them open and
on at the moment thank you very much
we move on
um I'd now like to call upon councilor
newgrosh to respond on behalf of the
liberal Democrat group thank you
thank you mayor I would like to begin by
thanking officers for all their help and
support getting this balanced budget to
us particularly Graham Bentley for his
guidance and advice
I'd also like to acknowledge the
considerable work put in by councilor
Ross who despite having the opportunity
to pass over the finance portfolio with
his recent promotion to leader decided
to put the interests of Trafford first
and deliver this budget alongside his
new role lib Dems will not begrudge him
should he decide this to be his last
budget holding the finance portfolio
much has already been made over the
considerable National challenges face
setting this budget and I think that it
just warrants the briefest of Recaps of
how we have arrived at this position
although many national failings led us
here one person's contribution stands
out the 49-day Prime Minister Liz truss
she left us with surging interest rates
saddling the UK with billions in extra
debt interest payments and requiring the
bank of England to step in to prop up
the entire final salary pension Market
it is the repercussions of that moment
of hubris which resonate in the figures
we debate tonight
add into the mix the death by a thousand
Tory cuts to Local Government funding
compounded by the Calamity of brexit and
challenging is certainly a euphemism
that summarizes the perilous state of
local government finances
the liberal Democrats note that the
total budget spend of Trafford council
is up 8.7 percent however due to the
disastrous incompetent mismanagement of
the economy economy by this Tory
government this negates that increase
spending total has been achieved by a
combination of tax Rises regrettably set
to the maximum for the next three years
and the vital retention of business
rates it is deeply regrettable that this
includes a series of Highly contentious
and deeply unpopular Community Asset
disposal sales particularly in timpley
and altering them
even with these council tax Rises
business rates and highly contentious
sales the council has still not been
able to balance the books without yet
another significant dip into our
reserves to the tune of 9.48 million
over the next three years
still deemed to be within the bounds of
prudent by our finance officer but I
think everyone here can agree it's not a
place we as a council are pleased to
find ourselves
I'd like to take a moment to draw all
the councilors attention to the warnings
written in bold by our 151 officer in
his conclusion clearly stating his
serious concern for the coming years
warning us against complacency one day
these reserves will run out counselors
we have been warned
of course with every budget there are
spending priorities and choices that
weed liberal Democrats warmly welcome
funds towards key areas of adult social
care children services school and
support for the most vulnerable
residents who have been so badly let
down by the Tory government
we warmly welcome 3.2 million funding
allocated to Trafford assist which
includes a commitment to provide free
School meals over holidays to support
ten thousand families
and recognize the crucial work that
Trafford assists play supporting our
residents and acknowledge that these
extra funds will deliver targeted
results for those most in need
the liberal Democratic group acknowledge
and welcome the extended council tax
support scheme to assist 13 400 of our
lowest income residents eighty percent
of which will be shielded from council
tax charges
I would like to take a moment to expand
on how the government has failed to get
a grip with social care
workers
were lauded as Heroes during the covid
pandemic but the reality is they do not
get a fair deal in this country as we
come to terms with the realities and the
needs of an aging population it is
becoming increasingly clear that the
future health of our communities depends
on the health of the social care sector
but people are leaving the caring
professions at an alarming rate Mr Mayor
the charity skills for skip for care has
reported that more than 50 000 care
workers quit the sector in the year
21-22
here in Trafford we currently have
almost 600 vacancies a vacancy rate of
10 percent across social care joint
worst in Greater Manchester
so yes there are local factors that this
Administration must address yes we must
look closely at Fair pay working
conditions and career progression so
that we can hire train and keep the best
care workers here in Trafford but this
is a national crisis in Social care
compounded by brexit and the effects of
the loss of European workers the
conditions during the pandemic and the
higher wages in alternative jobs
and these require National Solutions too
that's why the liberal Democrats have
called for a care as minimum wage that's
an extra two pounds an hour more than
the normal minimum wage for Frontline
carers
this Council should throw its support
behind this policy because it represents
a step forward a step towards a
transformation of social care sector
from a low paid unsustainable profession
to a viable rewarding career path with a
high status it deserves
Mr Mayor that is a transformation that
this country and our Borough desperately
need to realize
as you'd expect for not an opposition
group there are areas that we just
cannot accept
for for us the issue that stands out is
how poor a deal this budget is for our
residents in timperley
the budget seals a fate of timpley
community center the riddings this fine
Victorian building has been at the heart
of community life in timperley for
decades it was a vibrant sentiment first
leased by local trustees laterally run
and managed by our local GeForce charity
the amazing Paul and Tina Huxley the
basement of this building hosted the
recording studio of our local hero and
paper mache headed Superstar Frank
sidebottom
his Brawn statue raised entirely by
public subscription stands at the very
heart of timpley Village but his office
was the basement of timberley Community
Center
in recent years this building this
community resource has either been
cynically run down or incompetently
managed by this Council I will leave it
to the public to decide just which
our local Heritage run down for disposal
I know councilors may scoff but this
could have been could still become a
Frank side bottom Museum and Community
Center it's worthy of a blue pack not a
bulldozer
when the statue was unveiled we had
International TV crews in timpley
perhaps The timpley Tourist Board could
yet help put Trafford back on the map
moving on I've scoured this budget to
see if it bestows any targeted spending
on timpley surely some compensation for
losing a key local asset
and there just one line something I've
personally long campaigned on a safety
Improvement at Thorley Lane and shaft be
Avenue Junction
enough for the much needed redesign that
will decrease collisions and make it
safer for our residents so thank you it
will make a difference but beyond that
one solitary line in the budget that
doesn't appear to be a single yard of
Road in timpley scheduled for
maintenance or resurfacing of course
Road repairs should be allocated on need
but it Beggars belief they're not a
single stretch of road and timpley is
deemed in need of repair in the coming
Financial year
so in despite some of the benefits this
budget will bring to Trafford the lib
Dem Greek group feels the loss of our
timpley community center combined with
the lack of
capital investment in the south of the
borough and the lack of real commitment
to prioritize a climate emergency and
for these reasons we feel we cannot
support this budget thank you
thank you councilor newgrash
may I now call upon councilor Jerome to
respond in behalf of the Green Party
thank you Jeff
first of all I have to thank the finance
team putting this budget together is no
easy task the government don't make it
easy for councils the final settlement
is delivered days before Christmas in
multiple parts and needs to be carefully
untangled it is then calculated and
delivered into the budget we have before
us
these reports are always expertly
communicated and the team take great
care to help councilors to get to grips
with it so as ever thanks Graham and the
team
but thank you to all the the work at
this Council since 2010 the austerity
program has Stripped Away Local
Government funding year on year this
barbarity has brought this country to
its knees there must must have been a
collective fear from local authorities
many on the brink that they would simply
go under this financial year the budget
simply wouldn't balance therefore I
believe even this conservative
government has started to recognize that
proper funding is needed
the first bit of good news came in the
Autumn statement this has helped
alleviate the immediate pressures of
adult and social care funding but only
in the short term by pausing the
charging regime
the December settlement however has
given powers to raise council tax
further for 2023-24 the two percent
increase for adult and social care and
the 2.99 for General spending have
helped councils stumble Over The Line in
traveler's case filling an 8.5 million
Hull
however we are still needing to raid our
budget reserves by 3.7 million this
coming year 40 of the budget support
reserve a stick in cluster that doesn't
solve the problem of recurring costs
the government rather than solving the
fun fun fair funding problem for
councils is again passing the problem on
to our residents most people will be
seeing an increase of around 72 pounds
this year on the next financial year and
in the region of 200 pounds over the
next three
the cost of living crisis is already
hitting families hard but also we have a
wages crisis pay has never been
suppressed for so long and by so much
since the Napoleonic Wars and it's not
only Trafford three quarters of local
authorities will be taking the step of
increasing council tax by the full five
percent
the government need to tackle Fair
funding of councils and as the f-20
campaign is shown Trafford has a
historically for low funding scheme most
recent section 114 councils over the
last 18 months surik Slough and Croydon
have all had extra funding and in some
cases has had their council tax raised
by as high as 10 percent by government
Fair funding settlements rather than the
usual cuts
this budget shows there is still a great
deal of volatility business rates
allocation adult social care funding and
assumptions around energy costs and
inflations all remain potential problems
the finance and change program will need
to make continual savings to address
further funding gaps totaling 17 million
over the medium term from 2024 to 26. we
can't keep rating reserves and an
example of this can be seen by our
estate strategy the council offloading
property assets as quickly as possible
one example being Altrincham Town Hall
we're taking our time could have
resolved marketing issues Community
buy-in and possibly a better future for
this asset but no it needs to be moved
on quickly to remove liability
maintenance costs and so forth
there are a number of good things in
this budget we applaud continued support
for the vulnerable the extension to
council tax support scheme so 80 of
claimants on low income will now have
any council tax to pay and 3.2 million
through the Trafford assist scheme and
provision to support families during
school holidays
also the 16.27 for the modernization of
our Leisure centers including the
carbonization work and also the leveling
up Grant to Partington for a sport
Village is excellent use
also the continued regeneration and
revitalization of our town centers
include alteringham and Stratford is
vitally important in these economically
challenging time making these
destinations where people want to go as
crucial our local business businesses
need to support and they also need to
fall that makes their businesses viable
however the green party will continue to
ensure that these local centers are
accessible for all and safe and
welcoming by public transport and active
travel
finally the treating treat treatment of
our government of Asylum Seekers has
been shocking the broken system has
deposited vulnerable people and families
in places like Ashley hotel that just
isn't equipped to deal with the complex
needs this has been
been done at short notice without the
necessary support and the communication
with traffic Council has the Trafford
with the traffic Council has been dire
the green party has been consistent in
showing a compassionate response which
looks to support these people that are
often fleeing the most desperate
circumstances this issue can only become
a place this issue can often become a
political football and councilor
Leicester has led on a mature and
compassionate approach we welcome the
7.5 million local Authority housing fund
to provide long-term sustainable
accommodation for Ukraine and Afghan
families and those from other countries
the green party has often LED where
others have followed our climate
emergency from 2018 set this Council on
the path to Net Zero our pesticide free
motion the following year recognized the
importance of our environment and
biodiversity
in an economic in an Econo ecology
crisis that threatens mass extinction
and we haven't stopped this year Council
councilor Wilton successfully provides
proposed our vision zero emotion it
sounds sets a plan for eradicating
deaths and serious injuries on our roads
over the next 15 years it would defined
how we spend our transport budget in
future
following us this up we propose the
motion to review parking policy for
clean air and climate this could help
raise the desperately needed Revenue
within our transport budget which we can
reinvest in our vision zero making the
polluters pay it was great to see that
our requests for a task and finish group
to empower this work was granted even
before we made the wish
therefore it is disappointing that the
current 2023-24 integrated transport
program is investing so little of the
money we need to see only 65 000 will be
spent on 20 mile an hour speed limit
program as councilor Coggins has stated
time and again this piecemeal program is
more costly in the long run and misses
out on the benefits of bringing the
whole Borough into 20 mile an hour by
default now
there's only a music measly 35 000 for
school streets there's only been one
edition and five years of this labor
Administration we need to see this
rolled out with urgency we need to
protect our children both in road safety
and from polluted air we need to break
car dependency making our streets and
safe for all Road users alongside this
our Highway tree program has seen a ten
thousand pound reduction from 2022 to 23
budget this is an immensely popular
scheme with residents increases
biodiversity and helps to alleviate
roadside pollution
is it really necessary necessary to make
Cuts here surely this is a budget area
we should be boosting
there is a recognition that the council
is making progress on our climate
emergency however we still don't have a
meaningful carbon budget that works
alongside the financial one
this is what councilor Goggins asked for
and it's been almost five years
this is acknowledged by our finance team
therefore we can't measure progress and
we can't effectively hold to account on
these issues one of the greatest
economists of our time Sir Nicholas
Stern said climate change is the result
of the greatest market failure the world
has seen and he also went on to say in
2008 those who damage others by omitting
Greenhouse greenhouse gases generally do
not pay
so we need this carbon budget the data
needs to be provided provided to allow
us to see how we manage our finances and
where the work needs to be done
there needs to be a stronger direction
of travel from this Administration our
investment strategy which brings in a
dividend close to six million a year now
has a stronger set of principles behind
it sustainability is now a key principle
this has been shown in the components of
many of the schemes however we still
have no green info investments in this
portfolio
when this Council and region should be
investing in solar schemes and other
local renewable projects so far there is
nothing to show though we do welcome the
transformation of Trafford Park as a
future provider of cleaner clear energy
the council is also still investing in
large amounts of money in the Carrington
Link Road this will increase pollution
and carbon emissions Manchester Airport
which has already received loans of 9
million from this Council during covid
can still jaw down on another 3.2
million highlighted in this budget from
Project Mir
there is still no plan for the for how
this airport will reduce its carbon
emissions in the medium term and we
shouldn't be taking this air and relying
on rebuilding this dividend
overall we understand the constraints
that are present in making this budget
and we
um welcome Tom councilor Ross's work
diligent work in putting this but
helping to put this budget together but
there is also much to welcome and
support but the green party will be
voting against this budget we need to
see a proper carbon budget in place more
urgency Around clean air in the climate
sanctuary
thank you councilor Jerome
I remind everyone that the length of
speeches for members wishing to speak is
a maximum of three minutes a maximum of
three minutes
please can I therefore urge members to
keep their speeches concise and to the
point to avoid any further reductions
from the figure of three minutes
please go now have a note of those
counselors wishing to speak
right
laughs
just bear with me for a moment sorry
who is it behind Freeman who is it
behind
counselor Acton
a lady behind you this um
Oxford into you
she's the one with the Tuscan finished
group
well I'll read a list of names and just
put oh put your hand up if I miss you
out of this list in nope as they say no
particular order
um accounts I've got counselors Hartley
Patel Carter Jones Williams Wright
Harding Heinz Freeman Axford but wet and
Myers Welton Acton and Duncan
so I just I've got Carter
all right
sorry sweet all right all right okay
it's later
just later sorry
oh sorry I probably didn't see your hand
so we got such as Carter G Carter
yesterday's ad said so I've now added
I've now added Slater ad said second
Carter sorry
um
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten twelve thirteen
so I've now got 19 19 speakers okay
um
right off we go
um a lot of them just choose an order uh
which I hope you'll bear with me on that
one and we'll kick actually I'll tell
you who's going to come next as well I
think so each time
um we'll kick off with councilor Hartley
to be followed by councilor Jed Carter
thank you
thank you mayor I hope heartily commend
the lead of the council members of the
executive the Director of Finance and
all the council staff who've worked hard
yet again to deliver a balanced budget
I'd like to say something about council
tax I know a lot of residents will be
concerned about the increase in council
tax that's proposed and it's not a
decision that the council makes lightly
and I know when we talk about the
financial challenges facing the council
and savings proposals that are being
made a lot of residents say to us but my
council tax is going up and other
speakers not least the leader have set
out well the dire circumstances of local
government Finance
and the extent of budget gaps and
funding cuts that have occurred since
. so although council tax will go up
local government Finance overall has
decreased by 15 billion pounds from 2010
to 2020.
this year's funding settlement from
central government does contain some
welcome news some cash injections to
social care
but as I said in the in the budget
debate last year the government's
funding a settlement yet again bakes in
an assumption that council tax Will Rise
by the maximum possible
so an increase in council tax is the
government's chosen methods for councils
across the country to just about Keep
Their Heads above water
to illustrate the long-term challenge
that Trafford faces and will continue to
face
the council tax income that we'll
receive under this budget will be about
112 million pounds that's about 58 of
our income the rest comes from other
sources
if you take just children's services and
adult social care just those two areas
the revenue budget spending on those two
areas is 113 nearly 114 million pounds
so the council tax income doesn't either
cover the cost of just those two areas
of the Council budget areas where
demands and costs are growing
and I think it's it's telling that none
of the opposition parties have proposed
an amendment to the budget but they're
happy to criticize the balanced Fair
budget that's been presented to them
tonight
now you might say that's just the
politics of opposition but I would say
it tells you one of two things either it
shows how difficult setting a balanced
budget is in the current climate meaning
the opposition parties cannot come up
with any palatable or prudent
alternative
or it tells me that the opposition
parties are not ready and do not aspire
to the responsibility of leading this
Council
Trafford will still have the second
lowest council tax in Greater Manchester
we are one of the lowest spending
councils in the country and as we
debated at the last council meeting we
are one of the worst funded councils in
the country rather than pitting local
authorities against each other in
competition for a small slice of an
ever-shrinking pie of leveling up
funding it's time that the government
properly recognized and properly funded
the vital public services that local
councils deliver to their residents
thank you
thank you councilor Hartley as I said
the next speaker would take from
councilor Jed Carter to be followed by
councilor Buck thank you
thank you very much um
uh perhaps you could raise your hand and
be surprised that over half the recent
blowing up fund went to one local
Authority in the Northwest uh
conservative local for authority and an
opportunity to miss
cancer I work with some specific
elements of the capital of Russian
investment to repair and maintain any
perimeter wall of flexible garden and
much loved asset and investment very
well putting some new playground
equipment
during the revenue budget it's great to
see Cooperative support at one traffic
is adding value to the Sterling work but
the friends of chasten Park
we suffered over a quarter of a billion
pounds in real term funding cuts since
directors traffic Council last year I
heard a Chancellor's recommendation of
five percent increase in council tax
which with double digit inflation is
still a real-time cost
serious we're accepting your budget
based on a balanced budget based on
manifest
as Frank is breathtaking to her
councilor Morgan suggested a lower
Council against his Chancellor
assumptions I'll check my picture now
to see if there's a popular controllers
alternative budget in the advertisement
thank you councilor Carter as Speaker
next councilor but to be followed by
councilor Williams thank you
thank you Mr Smith uh I'd also like to
thank the uh
the Audi team the budgie team but the I
wanted to concentrate on the set for the
national the chartered Institute of
public finances and accountancy the
National Audit office requires our
external Auditors to formally consider
whether the council has made proper
arrangements for securing value for
money the assessment focuses around
Financial sustainability governance and
improving economy efficiency and
Effectiveness where are we then with the
external Auditor's annual report for
which the council taxpayer is now
expected to pay 180 000 pounds
we should have had a statement of
opinion on this budget from the external
Auditors so that Trafford Council
taxpayers can show confidence and expect
better services from this labor
Administration with its further almost
five percent increase in council tax
thank you Mr Mayor
thank you councilor Bott councilor
Williams next to speak followed by
councilor Jones thank you
um thank you chair I know that there's
many members wishing to speak this
evening so I'll try to keep my comments
brief did they want to speak um shortly
about the consequences that this budget
will have for the climate change and
transport strategy work undertaken by
the local Authority
I'm so pleased to confirm that in spite
of the huge financial pressure faced by
the council as outlined by Council of us
which I've had already known to be one
of the 20 poorest-funded councils in the
country this Administration has driven
forward its ambition to further invest
in tackling the climate emergency this
labor Administration has protected in
full the council's financial
contribution towards city of trees
greater Manchester's ambitious plan to
put plant over one million trees across
the city region and we have dedicated
specific funding to trouble the officer
capacity of council officers employed
specifically to work towards achieving
the council's carbon neutral objectives
this Administration has employed an
additional cycling and walking officer
and a significant proportion of this
budget's Capital spend includes highways
infrastructure spending secured from the
mayor's challenge fund to improve active
travel provision
with work due to commence on the ground
in the next couple of months and to
continue over the course of the next
Municipal year significantly enhancing
the walking wheeling and cycling offer
in the Bubba in addition to this so much
of the exciting work being driven
forward over the next year cannot fully
be given Justice in a report on the
council's parents is as detailed as it
is
discount this work being undertaken this
includes work being undertaken in
collaboration with greater Manchester
combined Authority as well as our
increasing decarbonation decarbonization
activities expanding in collaboration
with Amy under our one traffic
partnership
this is an Administration that is always
prepared to listen and reflect and I
heard exactly what councilor Morgan had
to say earlier in respect of recycling
um recycling provision in the Bubba and
I just wanted to assure councilor Morgan
that that's exactly why this
Administration just a couple of months
ago made the decision to bring our waste
awareness officers back in-house as
Trafford employees under a Trafford
contract there is no complacency on the
part of this Administration chair
which uh this budget is a positive news
story for the fight to combat climber
change and the effort to improve up of
his infrastructure and I commend it to
full Council thank you chair
thank you councilor Williams uh next to
speak councilor Jones to be followed by
councilor Welton thank you yeah thank
you Lord mayor and thank you to the
officers and Tom Ross for all the hard
work he's put into constructivist budget
and speaking in support of the 22
million pound highways maintenance
Capital program in this budget this is
most welcome and I know my fellow labor
councilors appreciate the frustration of
residents with the state of road
maintenance in Trafford
it's been immensely difficult to balance
the budget provide statutory
responsibilities like social care and
fix the roads in the last five years
after the roads were under maintained by
the conservatives pre-2018 also as we
have heard transfers has had to make 170
million pounds in budget savings and
it's acknowledged as one of the most
unfairly funded councils in the country
as acknowledged by the conservatives at
the last council meeting in support of
trafford's participation in the F20
group of councils this year the
conservative governments of forcing
Trafford to remove Millions more from
our budget
Trafford labor of balanced budget built
a budget for the future of Trafford and
we are taking big steps continuing to
clear the highways Mainstay backlog with
this 22 million pound capital investment
there's Capital funding for patching
resurfacing surface dressing is making a
real difference under this labor Council
crosswords in Trafford
traffic boards like Brooklyn's in
Brooklyn in the last Financial year 2223
we have seen major patching resurfacing
dressing work in residential roads all
around Brooklyn's in places like Eastway
and Walton Road Woodburn Road and it
surrounding roads Cumberland Road and
Hume Road totaling 162
871 pounds and 6p
I know it's important because people um
look into these figures in 2023
traffic councilors of um labor
councilors have secured 225
000 100 000 pound for Brooklyn's road
maintenance with road maintenance of
Norris Road and The Grove
Jonas winter I've heard many times from
many frustrated residents about Norris
Road as being badly affected by the road
surface deterioration residents have
been happy to hear that brooklands and
sell more councilors have secured 205
000 pounds for patching repairs for the
full length of Norris Road not just a
few patches like it's been done this
week I'm proud to support this fifth
Labor budget and it's not just balancing
books but building for Trafford future
and fixing roads and I'm looking forward
to many more budgets just to say the
conservatives talk about getting back on
track and they're campaigning they can't
even provide an alternative budget
tonight let no make any sensible
amendments to this budgets and it's very
disappointing that they can't even
support it thank you
thank you councilor Jones we moved to
councilor welcome to be followed by
councilor Patel thank you
thanks chair
um I'm going to highlight some aspects
of the budget that will be of importance
to Residents in altrium and hail but I
also make no excuse for um for
channeling uh councilor Freeman whose
last meeting it is and will be much
missed uh he's chuntering down the aisle
always amusing
funding uh funding for replacement
player equipment in navigation in
Stamford Parks is extremely welcome but
it has to be said at the time it takes
for items being taken up from being
items being taken out of action to a
replacement being authorized remains too
long and I think that's the case all
over Trafford two years or more without
an item of key equipment is a long time
in the lives of local children and we
still await progress on the replacement
of long time missing swings in cow field
we're aware how hard it is for the
council to rescue our road network from
the catastrophic underinvestment of the
Tory Years and we're happy to see major
work in the budget for Hale Road which
presents a major Hazard to all Road
users in its current state but pick
cyclists including myself attempting to
avoid the many defects towards the
curbside residents of Grobe Road will
also be relieved that they're the
long-standing issues on their street are
being addressed it's great to see for
the first time separate budgets for
school streets and 20 mile an hour
limits in the integrated transport
program and we look forward to finding
out if some of this money will be spent
addressing the many requests made by
residents and schools in our area
however the very limited funding on
offer will still mean Safe Streets are
for the few in Trafford not the many
and we are still far from the level of
investment needed to meet the targets
set out in the new Walking wheeling and
cycling strategy
ultram's public realm work demonstrates
the transformation that investment can
bring
the continued funding in this budget
will bring our town center its first
segregated cycle Lanes along with wider
Pavements narrower roads and rainwater
Gardens making the Town Center a safer
more attractive place for people
visiting local shops and businesses when
it is finished and you see people
enjoying it remember that even this
limited exercise in reclaiming Road
space for people rather than Vehicles
was opposed by local tourists
we particularly look forward to seeing
the results of the major investment in
Ultram Leisure Center this year and next
another asset that the Tories ran down
during their years in charge and
subsequently tried to weaponize for
electoral gain when out of power
the same can be said for Ultram Town
Hall ignored and unloved under the
Tories and now the subject of calls to
save it from the very people who wasted
the power to turn it around in the first
place but in the green group unlike the
Tories we don't want to see the council
have to keep budgeting for a loss making
asset that it clearly lacks the skills
and will to run we want to see those who
care most for the building those who
have the experience and enthusiasm to
make the ex to make it a success given
the opportunity to run it at a public
venue before it is lost as a community
asset for a quarter of a century or
perhaps for good thank you
thank you councilor Walton
um as I said next speaker will be
councilor Patel to be followed by
councilor wetton thank you thank you I
would like to draw out some
polit we have secured over 100 million
pounds of external Capital grant money
for the period 23-26 this will support
investment into our Town Center's new
affordable homes sport facilities
Leisure centers parks and Open Spaces we
will invest this as always fairly across
the borough and in response to need
in a time when councils are forced to
compete with other councils for various
ring fence funding pots devoting
considerable and already strict
resources to bidding processes with no
fixed outcomes comes with its own risks
and I wanted to highlight this in its
own right that we have done so well
speaks to the quality of our
applications the talents of our offices
and the support this process receives
from this Administration
whilst a period of stability in Local
Government funding is well overdue we
will continue to prioritize this work to
secure every last pound possible for
Trafford
among the many Investments the council
is making this year into our communities
I would like to highlight the ongoing
work as just mentioned in Ultram Town
Center through our joint venture work
with Brentwood which includes for the
current work on site with within the
former rackhams building and the ongoing
public realm works there and most just
as excitingly after some years in the
planning work will begin on re on the
Regeneration of stretford town center
imminently
at a time of economic uncertainty we
will continue to Target investment to
boost our local economy and create jobs
acting as a reliable partner to
Residents businesses and developers
thank you
thank you councilor Patel next speaker
please councilor wetton to be followed
by councilor Wright thank you
thank you thank you Mr Mayor and firstly
can I also thank Graham Brentley and his
team certainly a great resource to this
Council
Mr Mayor we recently uh saw reported
that a budget to a very large English
local Authority has reached 1 billion
pounds
the demands of that scale of budget
don't bear thinking about accept to note
the significance of local government
within the national economy
it is a huge proportion of government
spending it impacts the national economy
hence governments of all shades all
shades
have had to keep local government
spending rained in
this budget is substantially bigger than
the last one large due I believe to
inflation but it is bigger and it has
been balanced
now a significant player in that
balancing going forward and in The
Current financial year is the change to
minimum Revenue provision
in effect the repayment of capital is
pushed back much like the way a
traditional mortgage works
the change to MRP is what saves the day
with this budget and also with the
budget of the year to date
I don't criticize the change I just
wanted to highlight it
it is one being undertaken by a number
of councils because of its effectiveness
remember though there's no such thing as
a free lunch
this change leaves pressure now
and applies pressure again in about 20
years time
by then though inflation may make those
repayments more manageable
irrespective the requirement to repay
will still be there
we've seen the report with 40 percent of
reserves being consumed by this budget
the change to MRP is obviously essential
not doing it would further increase that
percentage of reserves being consumed
and that could well set alarm bells
ringing
I'll just connect this change to the
current years I'll connect this change
to the current years forecast overspend
and I don't take issue with the
overspend forecast for the current year
it was always going to be a difficult
year
and I did observe 12 months ago that
more Provisions were needed for
inflation energy and payroll in part
because of Russia poisoning itself for
war
I did suggest moving reserves between
headings to make a larger General
Reserve too and I'm not being clever
because I'm not qualified those were the
easy calls to make
but reserves strategically are marvelous
particularly in this scenario reserves
are the lifeblood of council accounting
and I think it's true to say officers
love Reserves
they can be the friend of council
finances
so be mindful I'm almost finished Mr
Mayor we see this budget it's greatly
into reserves 40 percent we're told this
Narrows scope in future years the change
to MRP moves pressure to 20 years from
now maybe this chamber will look very
different in 20 years but those
repayments will still need paying and
the interim years will present their own
challenges thank you Mr Mayor thank you
councilor wetton uh moved to councilor
right to be followed by councilor Acton
thank you thank you chair I wanted to
focus on the delivery of housing under
this Administration and and how despite
a difficult economic background this
Council continues to show its commitment
to housing growth in this Borough
despite members of the government
fighting to acknowledge how important
the housing growth is to the economic
success of an area this Administration
recognizes that without new homes being
built of all types affordable market and
for rent we will not grow our economy
and take advantage of the benefits this
brings
from the extra council tax receipts to
reducing our waiting list and improving
the health and well-being of our
residents we recognize how important
house building is
there is nothing more important in life
than having a secure roof over your head
there's those that continually attempt
to deny others this opportunity should
think about either how they would feel
if they were living in a bed and
breakfast with their family unable to
cook a simple meal and having to share
facilities with others
in the past quarter Trafford has seen
528 new homes completed across the
borough and 149 of these are affordable
units this is 28 of all homes bills a
significant percentage on one that has
increased year on year since we took
control of the council in 2018. there
are a further 465 affordable units
approved with the vast majority having
commenced on site
despite the difficult economic backdrop
made far worse by a government who far
sickly still try and call themselves
fiscally responsible we are delivering
on one of our biggest priorities and
will continue to do so thank you chair
thank you councilor Wright the next
speaker has said the councilor Acton to
be followed by councilor Heinz
thank you all right father Lang's
daughter
it was reported in today's newspaper
that the leader of Bournemouth Council
atori Flagship has stood down blaming
the chancellor for forcing council tax
Rises on Town Halls
the leader
of Bournemouth wrote a scathing
resignation letter that said due to the
treasury the future of local government
is one of Maximum council tax and cuts
to service now this is an honest story
with good principles I would say
and I think that the leader of
Bournemouth has summed up how Tory
government is slowly but surely trying
to kill off local government in England
however
this labor Council will fight this
government and not let this local
Council and our communities are now
residents to wither away under the
Tories
however despite the Tory cuts of and
austerity for 12 years
and now the cost of living crisis
our labor Council has produced a
balanced budget and Improvement in many
services and I'm proud
to support our Labor budget thank you
Matt
thank you councilor Acton as I said next
to it will be councilor Heinz
to be followed by councilor Freeman
thank you mayor and like like daughter
like father and I too am proud to
support this budget
um aligned with the leaders priorities
and those of this Administration I would
like to highlight our continued
commitment to the children and young
people of Trafford we're increasing our
spend on children's services by an
additional 4.5 million pounds on last
year's spend to over 48 million pounds
which brings the total additional spend
to our young people to 16.5 million
pounds more which is 51 and a half
percent more since we became the
administration in 2018 that's a
staggering increase in investment in the
children of arbora and the council was
praised by ofsted for our significant
investment and the minister has praised
Trafford for the change in culture
across the service to one which focuses
on the child and that is absolutely as
it should be but without the required
investment from central government this
is incredibly challenging to do members
may be aware of the recent outcome of
the government's appointed the
government appointed review of
children's social care in the UK which
emphasized the clear need to invest in
early help and intervention to help
children and families and to prevent
difficulties from escalating to be
effective in supporting and protecting
children the reports identified the
requirement for government to invest an
additional 2.6 billion pounds but to
date they've only put forward 200
million which is a tiny fraction of the
required song and which is mostly made
up of money already allocated to local
authorities so isn't new or is money
that the council have to bid for which
pits authorities against each other an
effective flea means a lottery for the
lives of our most vulnerable of children
and that is just wrong and it has to
stop
and and we have to fund Services
properly because the underfunding of
social Care by Central governments is
actually one of the key reasons why we
have to raise council tax in the way
that we do so I'm actually sure that
members will be reassured to know that
in Trafford despite being one of the
lowest 20 funded councils in the UK and
despite being unsuccessful in our own
recent bid for government funding of
this nature we are actually going to
invest anyway in a strong early help
model and strong services to children
because this is the right thing to do
thank you mayor thank you councilor
Hines we moved to councilor Freeman to
be followed by councilor Myers thank you
thank you mayor this is going to be my
last ever council meeting after 11 years
so I'm sure some will be very glad to
see that me but hey that's how
politics works the budget before us
today is Testament to the hard work this
labor Administration have put in since
we took control of this Council in 2018.
now I recall our years in opposition
when the Tory is over there level that
is that we had no plan no idea and no
clue so it's really good to see that
that is now firmly pinned on them and
let me say you are very welcome of that
label and very deserving of it unlike
the Tories when they were in control
this labor Administration has given a
Clear Vision and direction as to the
sort of Trafford we all want to live in
one that is caring compassionate
inclusive where no one gets left behind
where our children are supporting offer
the best start in life indeed a Trafford
that is a great place to live in grow up
in and working and our corporate plan
which I'm really proud of underpins
everything that we do none of this would
have been possible without the efforts
of all of our Council officers and staff
and I pay tribute to them all all for
the part they've played and my goodness
are they really deserving of our support
and praise
so mayor I've been proud to have been
part of an Administration which has
built social and affordable housing
which has rescued our children's
services which have secured Monies to
the redeveloped Stratford and brought
forward plans for other Town centers
which has rescued our Leisure Services
which has brought to two Care Homes
which has supported places for everyone
and which are successful navigated this
Council through the pandemic and which
more importantly year on year has
balanced the budget whilst improving
services and all this with no thanks to
Central conservative government I heard
what councilor Morgan had to say the
funding of Metropolitan local
authorities can only be described as
lamentable and in the cost of living
crisis the Tories Force up council tax
then blame the rise on councils what
cowards you are
we on this side have a lot to be proud
of and I've been delighted to play my
part I want to thank everyone in the
chamber for being colleagues for these
past 11 years we might not have always
seen eye to eye but a genuinely believe
each and every one of us has have tried
in our own way to make a difference and
that is the core work of a local Council
representing the views of and advocating
for local residents I ask that we all
support this budget before us I wish
this Council and you all the very best
for the future thank you
thank you thank you for all your
comments there councilor councilor
Freeman we moved to councilor Myers to
be followed by councilor Axford thank
you
yes thank you Mr Mayor I'd like to talk
about
um Street lighting and kind of refer
members to appendix K on page 110.
um you'll see there that the there are
two proposals about street lights and
one is to reduce the level of the street
Lighting in other words to to dim them
and the second is to switch them off uh
switch them on earlier and off later
I've got that the right way around I
think so maybe it's the other way around
the council actually undertook a a
survey of residence views but
unfortunately only 18 people responded
out of 185 000 residents so the results
of that I'm surprised really it was
actually reported because the results of
that are fairly meaningless
reducing Street lighting as councilor
Morgan already said tonight was in fact
in the 2020 budget
proposal which was against the uh the
view of the conservative members who
were here on that night
however councilman Denise Weston wrote
the uh wrote the support and if at the
following meeting the next meeting she
was able to persuade us to overturn that
decision and that decision was
overturned at that meeting and that was
following unfortunately the tragic
murders and a number of attacks on women
conservative members believe that this
is not the time to actually make our
streets more dangerous and I'd ask you
to consider dropping this soppy scheme
thank you Mr Mayor
thank you councilor Myers we moved to
council at Oxford to be followed by
councilor Slater thank you
to see that in these times of austerity
and enforce budget constraints Trafford
cancer showing real commitment to
tackling the climate crisis and meeting
our Target of carbon neutrality by 2038
thereby improving Trafford residence
Health while being quality of life and
protecting our most vulnerable I'm
especially pleased to see the plan to
Triple our dedicated officer team with
an additional two officer roles one at
head of service level so we can continue
to be Innovative and bold moving forward
in collaboration with the gmca
initiatives and better able to take up
the bidding opportunities we are so
sadly forced to make instead of
receiving the government funding we so
desperately need
in addition developing a carbon budget
alongside our financial budget as well
as a zero carbon energy plan
demonstrates our commitment to be fully
accountable
in order to meet our targets and to
improve our air quality and public
health it's important to reduce our car
dependency
Andy Burnham's recent two-pound fare Cup
in bus fares has already increased bus
duties by 10 in Greater Manchester
and in addition to the very welcome
active Travel network which is about to
start its first phase and the very
welcome investment in EV charging points
jafford Council will continue to explore
making our roads and Pavements safer and
more pleasant to walk and cycle along so
everyone has a real Choice how to move
around with the Trafford walking
wheeling and cycling strategy soon to be
published
in addition we're making a good start
decarbonizing our public buildings and
the launching of the green skills
academy is so exciting which will offer
our residents the opportunity to gain
the skills needed to secure the many new
jobs in the green sector
as counselors I feel we all bear
responsibility to ensure that we
mitigate the effects of climate change
and help reach greater Manchester's 2038
zero carbon challenge I feel confident
this budget allows us the opportunity to
to do the very best we can to achieve
this and I'd like to thank cancer Ross
and the officers for all their hard work
thank you thank you councilor Oxford we
moved to councilor Slater to be followed
by councilor Harding thank you thank I'd
like to thank Tom Ross the leader of the
council and Graham Bentley and his
officers who have worked incredibly hard
to set a balanced budget again this year
against a backdrop of never-ending
courts to councils as this government's
failed austerity plan continues to
decimate our public services and all the
services that our resident wants our
residents want like social care decent
roads homes and more
we've lost 290 million over the last 12
years from our budget can you imagine if
we had that money we wouldn't be using
reserves and we would be able to invest
a lot more in our services the stories
of all the Tories in government have
always treated local government as a
Cinderella service of the public sector
and they continue to show their contempt
for local government
the council should be applauded and
setting this balanced budget and instead
of and there has been no ripping up of
Staff terms and conditions or compulsory
redundancies and it is in the backdrop
of this of these courts it has become a
real living wage employer we should be
applauding
um the hard work of our our staff and um
to be able to have done this it's no
mean feat doing what we have done with
this budget and so I'd like to thank
this labor control Council for all the
work it has done to set this balance
budget and I will be supporting and the
budget when we come to the vote thank
you
thank you very much indeed we moved to
councilor Harding to be followed by
councilor Duncan
over there councilor Jerome mentioned a
piecemeal approach absolutely right and
I'm going to touch on a piecemeal
approach in a minute and thank you
councilor newgrash for your interest
into social care as a brand new exec
member I put forward the Unison ethical
care Charter I think this
administration's record stands that we
are absolutely committed to the future
of social care
I am incredibly proud of this labor
Administration and all that we have
managed to achieve during these
incredibly challenging times
we have and continue to invest in our
Leisure Services services that are on
some sites leaky unloved rundown and
dated so desperately in need of TLC TLC
that this Administration is providing
that sadly wasn't provided before
I'm also delighted that we're pushing
ahead with our culture strategy
why should culture not be a part of all
our residents lives not just a nice to
have for those that can access it
but that's what it feels like in local
government right now difficult policy
choices are nice to haves I certainly
didn't come into local government to
make people's lives worse none of you
did either yet increasingly this is what
is happening as local leaders and Ward
councilors we all feel passionately
about the area in which we live and the
people we represent what I am so tired
and frustrated of is the short-termism
that is local government Finance
councils received
448 individual government grants between
2015 and 16. increasingly fragmented and
firefighting the better care fund the
leveling up fund the adult discharge
fund the household support fund to name
but a few
more than a third of these grants were
then discontinued from one year to the
next having a negative impact on staff
Recruitment and long-term planning
and around a third of those grants were
awarded on a competitive basis you only
have to look at the debacle of the
leveling up fund councils pitching
against each other here in Trafford we
submitted three bids but we were only
successful for one and I'm delighted we
were successful with that one but it
shouldn't have to be that way we
shouldn't have to be begging for crumbs
at the table of local government Finance
homelessness Services have been issued
with 12 short-term grants since 2015.
how on Earth can we plan for the most
vulnerable in society with such a mashup
of funding
to conclude who is the enemy in this
room councilors it isn't this labor
Administration who have put together a
budget and a balanced budget and my ipot
on record my thanks to Graham Bentley
and his team too you should all be
supporting this budget and sending out a
message to this government that
short-termism is just not good enough in
local government anymore thank you mayor
thank you councilor Harding next to
speak councilor Duncan to be followed by
councilor ad said
yeah thank you chair I would just like
to ask um why the labor run Council seem
to spend money on road repairs that
don't really need it
however of decline roads
that are in much more need of repair
such as Hearst Avenue thirst Avenue and
Newgate Road in manawat
surely this is costing the taxpayer more
money in the long run
with regards to housing
I strongly request The Damp issues are
addressed on the Southwest estate I
repeat that again
I would also like to highlight that this
Council was run very successfully
between 2004 and 18 by a Trafford
conservative-led Council
budgets were managed roads were in a
better condition weed spraying was
better managed along with tree trimming
thank you chair
thank you councilor Duncan so we moved
to councilor adshead to be followed by
councilor Karina Carter thank you
proud to be speaking to the highway
proposal for the forthcoming year with
an investment just short of 10 million
pounds on our Highway infrastructure
this includes female impound on service
dressing type work which proved very
popular last year so I'm really pleased
to announce the rollout of the second
phase of this program and I say to
council new gross if you care to look at
the proposals for the service dressing
you may well find quite a number of
streets in Village Road will appear on
that list
and full details will be published
shortly
this work as well as helping to improve
the service and appearance but also
significantly extends life of the gold
and thereby saving public money and
making it safe to all Road users I'll
say to councilor Duncan they were
quickly that no roles have done that do
not need doing that with absolute
waiting on one is I spent on role
Saturdays in line with tfgm criteria for
such work and similar across all of GM
the work also includes in the program
includes fifty thousand pound on Highway
tree program
500 500 500 million 500 000 on Street
lighting I only wish and 325 000 pound
on separate Footwear work almost 1.8
million pound on these service and
reconstruction work that equates into
overcome five million pounds on Highway
structural maintenance work across the
bobber this together with the service
dressing work comes to around 9 million
pounds
and then to move on to my favorite the
integrated transport program we've
talked love over 770
000 pounds and this is safety type work
across the whole of the borough this
work will include minor Works program
and Cat which kind of itself include
things like pedestrian Islands which I
find really in valuable pedestrian Aid
in many locations the Pokemon does also
include schools to each 20 Zone stock
Crossings Collision analysis and
improvements for walking and cycling
helping to make all our streets safer
for all Road users and yes I would like
more resources and a dare say it's not a
member in this chamber who'll disagree
with that we've had more of this so much
more we could do and I personally would
like to see safety at the top of that
list just touch on a couple of points
from other members that they've made
there on councilor Morgan on Street
lighting what I'll simply say on that
one of course that where your
Administration introduced the LED
lighting what you forgot to do at the
time was taken up they do not need it
now to warm up like the old socks types
lanterns did they are instantaneously
and that's that was a Feeling on your
part you could have actually made that
saving that some time ago without any
effect on the lighting at all on Council
Jerome say quickly on the tree plantings
programs if you care to take note of
course is that we now work with city of
trees and city of trees responsible for
huge numbers of planting across the
connotation not just Trafford workers
holiday to Manchester and those figures
actually now need to be added to our
sorts of work as well you can get a more
accurate picture not just on a very
simple Baseline figure there and I'll
simply say that the amount of two upon
that's going is actually tremendous I
would actually say and I will leave it
and on that note thank you councilor as
said we moved to councilor Karina Carter
thank you
gagtastic
a very interesting report circulated
last week by our director of Public
Health Eleanor off entitled making good
decisions in hard times
and I think this excellent title sums up
our approach to the budget this year
there is no doubt that this task is
becoming harder each year as there is
nothing left to give
I'll Echo what councilor Harding said
none of us came into politics officers
nor councilors to make cuts to Public
Services
and this year the government has given
us permission to increase the council
tax in order to pay for the rising costs
of social care
a cost they have continually committed
to revising a service users are exposed
to potentially very high and
unpredictable care costs and it means
people face the prospect of losing the
majority of their income and their
assets
when I took on this portfolio last May
the government had just published the
draft guidance about how the social care
cap would work in practice
our teams here in Trafford were
gathering up to the changes gearing up
and I.T systems necessary
everyone was working towards the
introduction in October this year
and then poof last November Jeremy Hunt
scrapped this long and detailed piece of
work deciding instead that local
authorities shoulder the charges instead
the amount this Authority receives in
council tax does not even cover the cost
of social care in Trafford
let that sink in
for every resident who wants the roads
repaired and The Verge is cutting
because they pay their council tax the
simple fact is we do not collect enough
money from you to even pay for our
oldest and most vulnerable residents how
shocking is that
I've spent the last year visiting lots
of facilities I've seen members of the
Holly orchestra playing Cara house the
nursing home that we've brought in-house
a couple of years ago I've seen the
fabulous facilities at stockdale's
provide for disabled residents the music
created by a string of hearts with our
older population I've been privileged to
visit Ascot house our discharge from
hospital facility the beautiful bofile
house in flixon I've seen the amazing
work up close done by age UK Trafford
and the care is centered in sale
I've chat the a12 board and I've heard
of the activities for our older
population and I know many of you
including our mayor helped with the
distribution of the winter warmer packs
there are many more organizations in
Trafford working extremely hard to
improve the quality of life for our
older and vulnerable residents on
diminishing resources
but above all I have met marvelous
dedicated staff
who work under difficult circumstances
to protect and care for these residents
Council a new grush elaborated on this
but these staff bore the brunt of the
pandemic and they continue to work with
care and compassion towards the
residents they look after
so I was delighted to be able to bring
the report to the last executive that in
Trafford I can announce that all of our
home care agencies and two-thirds and
can continue certainly yeah
um and two-thirds of our Care Home
providers currently pay the real living
wage a significant increase from the
year year before
we know residential and Nursing Care
Homes have incurred significant and
unavoidable increases in the cost of
utilities food drink petrol also true of
home care agencies so I was delighted to
announce that we've been able to offer
an uplift of 9.17 to our residential and
nursing homes
8.74 to our home care agencies and this
additional funding will help maintain
our commitment to paying all staff the
real living wage and to continue to
support the sector to meet the rise and
cost of living
foreign
I've obviously run out of time about the
national picture and some of the
disgraceful Behavior we've seen in
Westminster
and then I just want to say this
behavior is so far removed from how
local authorities are continuing to
operate with Integrity prioritizing the
most vulnerable children and adults and
acting with care and diligence to the
residents that we serve we can proudly
say that in labor Trafford we are still
indeed making good decisions in hard
times and I want to support the budget
tonight thank you
thank you very much for that councilor
Carter that that concludes the speakers
that I had 19 speakers that represent
about a third of the chamber and I
welcome everybody's comments and their
what they said tonight and I think we've
had an extremely good debate or an
extremely good Exposition by all the
councils that have spoken so as agreed
at the beginning of the meeting the
opposition group leaders will now each
have five minutes to wind up beginning
with councilor Jerome thank you
thanks chair and I just wanted to come
back on a few of the comments that have
been made this evening and to councilor
Morgan
um three quarters of councils are
raising Council taxes for legal limit
Allowed by the government so it's
perfectly reasonable that Trafford are
doing that too under these Financial
circumstances but also dimming street
lights sensibly also decreases energy
use at the same time
to cancel a wetton I think you made some
really good points about the mrf another
example of how good this Financial
finance team is in in making the
arrangements for saving us money in the
long term their skill and aptitude is is
absolutely brilliant
and on councilor Harding uh coming back
on on the piecemeal statement on the 20
mile an hour limit program where I
mentioned that word this is piecemeal
intrafford and all the evidence that's
doing doing it in one go is cheaper and
brings forward the benefits to Residents
um just ask Wales who are committed to
applying this across the whole country
and it will be applied in September 2023
it's part of our vision zero which we
unanimously supported in this Council
and we can use our parking policy to
help pay for it in the future and um I
think I'm right but I think you put
forward a 20s plenty Motion in this
Council and now you're in administration
you seem to knock back 20s plenty
um so I
interesting comments I saw but um this
Council does need to be dynamic in the
years ahead we recognize a cruel
Financial pressures that this government
is keeping on on Trafford
and elsewhere and that the challenges
will only get harder however this
Administration have sometimes been slow
in putting forward the strategies that
can inform and direct this budget the
tree policy for instance arrived 18
months later than promised
laptop troubles
the clock this has also been the case
with the cycling and walking strategy
Nevermore have we needed the
communication and tools to enable and
encourage people out of their cars and
into cleaner modes of Transport we were
told this would be published in February
2022 but we were only just going through
the consultation stage now if we are
going to spend our money efficiently and
in a coherent way we need these
strategies and documents with more
urgency
there's also been a significant problem
with the consultation process in fact as
councilor Myers mentioned only 18 people
responded to the survey on this budget
in December which makes this process
less than meaningful
the hail Place band has also come back
twice and cycling schemes have been
similarly delayed on cycling we need to
communicate the strong public health and
climate reasons for these changes but
also we've seen the citizens climate
citizens assembly has also gone by the
wayside so less public and Resident
engagement engagement as we go forward
to help inform how we spend our money
but the climate emergency was passed in
November 2018 and it's coming up to its
fifth anniversary but still we have no
carbon budget that provides the data and
tools we need to manage this journey we
need to reduce emissions by 13 each year
to reach our 2038 Target but we have
little evidence to do this at the moment
but our carbon challenge will only hurt
us our finances and our future
Generations we do thank officers for the
adding carbon and sustainability to the
reports but there is still much work to
be done
we welcome the two new officers that
will be joining the place team over the
next year and hope this will help
transform the way we do our budgets in
future and move on the work and take the
work forward in Trafford Park too it's
also pleasing to see a cycling and
walking officer appointed and hopefully
as Council of accident says this will
help get those screen those schemes more
quickly onto the ground and also get
more money and investment from Grants
particularly the merge challenge fund
however the progress today has been far
too slow
um so few of them mayor challenge fund
money has actually resulted in schemes
on the ground we we need to more
evidence of progress and we won't be
supporting this budget sanctua
thank you councilor Jerome a closing
speech from now councilor new grosh
thank you
thank you Mr Matt uh I too wanted to
point out a couple of comments firstly
councilor Patel thank you for um saying
that the funding that we have received
is going to be shared amicably I I have
to say before this budget I'd never
worried about that I'd never thought
that I might be in some way
disadvantaged because I wasn't of a
labor member or in the north of the
borough but but when I looked at this
budget and I saw one line for timpley at
fifteen thousand pounds I was like where
is the spending Council uh and when I
hear that what my colleague in sale is
you know Norris Road at 205 000 pounds
it's like what have I done wrong
um and council ad said thank you for
informing us that we're going to get
that but it would have been nice to have
it in the budget so we could see we
could see the advantages of it
the actual specifics weren't there it's
just 300 yeah so it was because of this
that we took the view we took
um and we still based on a promise that
it will be coming so I I'm gonna hold
the executive to that
um I want to say that much been said
about Target spending in this budget
um however repeat the twin evils of
inflation eating into the budget and the
unfair allocation
um dealt out by warped Whitehall funding
means that it may seem to many were
residents in this Borough that they'll
be paying more every day that will look
around and see less and less I mean I
before I was told by council ad said I'd
calculated that we were going to be
spending a third of the required Road
resurfacing for the next three years and
that's the required for to maintain the
status quo but now I hear more is going
to be spent but also poor levels of
Maintenance of drainage trees and Street
lighting for example I've been waiting
over a year to get a single greater
great cleared on a road that that floods
often or perhaps the laissez-faire
attitude of bin collection from houses
and streets especially communal blocks
of Apartments where a single side bag
can cause an entire missed collection
and the disruption for many
and the lib Dem notes the leader's
renewed focus on getting the basics
right in his acceptance speech in the
new year
we've heard Focus measures towards those
Basics tonight and we will watch keenly
to see if those targeted measures lead
to the improved outcomes that we all
desire
and there's only if there's only one
thing I can ask as a takeaway from our
contribution to this budget It's A
Renewed request for a renewed effort on
the F20 group this work is now vital
if necessary we ask that Trafford taken
lead role on these in these negotiations
should these efforts be successful this
one funding change will provide a more
secure Financial footing for trafford's
future and we believe it's certainly
worth investing the time and effort to
achieve it certainly would go a long way
towards reducing the risk clearly
indicated in our section 151 officers
warning comments
so we've studied this budget line by
line and not forgetting the lines that
weren't there and I've listened to the
arguments for and against this evening
but on balance I'm going to leave our
last words to our local hero
who's recording studio is under the
hammer tonight and whose Village is so
poorly directly compensated for its loss
I feel pretty sure if you are still with
us you'd summarize this budget
especially for our residents of timpley
as this budget is bobbins
thank you councilor newgrosh now
a closing speech now from councilor Miss
Blackburn thank you
thank you Mr Mayor I'm not going to be
verbose I'm just going to be very quick
with this this closing speech thank you
to Graham Bentley all his team thank you
to our chief exec and the corporate
directors and all their offices for all
the work they've done in order to
produce tonight's budget
um our Council has a legal requirement
to deliver a balanced budget and it is
understood that the section one five one
officer and leader of the council must
consider sustainability and resilience
of the budgets going forward
economies all over the world have been
affected by both covid and the war in
Ukraine creating pressures up and down
all countries
this Administration is currently having
to make similar budget choices as we did
when we were in control of the the
council prior to 2018.
um we've not submitted an alternative
budget this year as was replicated by
labor when they were in opposition and
when you are
um sort of running the council you
always becry the opposition groups for
not putting in an alternative budget the
book the budget proposals this year were
published on the Tuesday with um a
requirement that by three days later on
the Friday the alternative budget would
would have to be submitted which isn't
really
um enough enough time to to get all that
information together there's a lot that
we do agree within the budget tonight
um I am very happy about
um monies going into into children's
services and we do have to protect our
most vulnerable it's it's important for
any political party to do so it's only
the right some proper thing
um
we note obviously that the um the
changes to council reserves are going to
remain very tight
and Prudence will have to be the byword
in the near future
um it is
um and and it was the same for the
conservative group that we've always
been a very low funded Authority it
isn't right
um and
you know it doesn't matter who is going
to be running Trafford you know we do we
do need um you know a bigger
um decision on on different allowances
um but
um as the Conservancy group we won't be
um supporting the budget tonight thank
you
thank you councilor Miss Blackburn so we
now moved to the leader to sum up the
wind up the whole debate thank you
councilor Ross
um we've heard a vast number of comments
this evening's a terrific number of
contributions
many have recognized the extreme
Financial circumstances that we continue
to face in the council many have praised
some of the items specific items in the
budget
and there have been other comments as
well
the council tax increases too high
there's not enough investment in X Y or
Z we're using too many reserves we're
not doing things quick enough
the last one completely dismissing and
ignoring the fact that we've just come
through a global pandemic where this Con
this this Council had to become reactive
and lead in an area of a complete
unknown for us
the messages that we have have been at
best mixed and Confused
if you don't put council tax up by the
government guidelines you have to find
at least 1.3 million pounds for per
percentage that you um that that you're
wishing to reduce it by that 1.3 million
pounds as someone else suggested we
couldn't get from reserves because we're
already according to two a couple of
people using too much in terms of
despite the fact that Graham Bentley has
confirmed that our budget is robust
if you look at some other things
we need to invest more in this I don't
particularly you know people saying I
don't particularly like this line of the
budget well where are you going to get
that money from if you don't do that
particular saving again council tax
we've got the limit that the government
have set down you can't go to reserves
because people have said you're using
too many reserves where do you get it
from it is a mishmash of different
things that just goes to show that
people do not get the reality of the
budget situation we face
so it has been interesting and when it
comes to an alternative budget proposals
what has there been
silence
nothing
and I have to say the proposals in this
budget have been out since October last
year members of political groups have
had plenty time to come forward work
with us look at different approaches if
there were any
I think this silence is an admission
that none of you none of the other
parties have an alternative for the
residents of this Borough
and people mention places as a timpley
resident of of 20 years before moving
away I have to say it's frankly
ridiculous that you don't think that
timpley residents are going to benefit
from say going to Orchard Leisure Center
with the refurbishment going there the
additional Millions pounds going into
children's and Adult Services and the
roads that my colleague councilor ad set
has pointed out to you
this is a budget for everyone in this
Borough and it is Trafford labor that
delivers for all residents of this Bora
and once again we have delivered a
robust budget that provides maximum
support to our Frontline services so I
have to say the fact that none of you
none of the other parties despite those
months of having this information could
come forward with an alternative it says
all it needs to say
foreign
now I started this evening by setting
out the many Financial challenges local
government faces however there is a
positive story to tell
it is my deep held belief that local
government is a significant Force for
good in the local community and this
labor Administration remains committed
to making a positive difference each and
every day
last month I set out my priorities as
leader of this Council and I want to
take the opportunity to briefly set out
how this budget supports them
starting with our aspiration to give
young people the best start in life
we're overseeing a net increase in the
Children's Service budget of almost 5
million pounds which includes net
investment in children's social care and
our education early year service
we're planning around 40 million pounds
worth of investment in schools and play
area refurbishment work in Stanford Park
abbotsfield Park navigation Park hallard
Park Ashton Park and Walton Park
moving on from that Sport and Leisure
will see a significant boost as people
have already confirmed today
we're going to continue our investment
in Leisure centers with work in
Altrincham plans for stretch to follow
and the exciting new plans for
Partington following our successful
level in Europe bid last month and I
have to say on that bid it just goes to
show how much care and attention was put
into that bid that the fact that we were
one of the few people to have got that
award and you know what the people who
parted and deserve every single pound of
investment in that and I'm so pleased
they're getting it
we're also continuing our vest
investment in parks and open spaces and
Outdoor Sports facility provision
in terms of affordable housing and
regeneration we'll be prioritizing an
increase in the availability and range
of suitable housing we propose 30
million pounds of support for our town
center regeneration schemes and our
asset investment strategy continues to
support regeneration projects in Borough
turning to access at help with time to
help a time of need net investment in
Adult Services of almost 4 million
pounds we're taking action to support a
more sustainable care Market council tax
support extended with 80 percent of
claimants receiving 100 relief we're
investing 3.2 million pounds in
supporting families via Trafford assist
and we would propose continued funding
of our hubs across the borough
net carbon zero we're investing more
resource to help accelerate progress
with our net carbon zero agenda we're
expanding the number of EV charging
points on a revenue share model
and we want to increase the pace at
which we deliver our active travel
schemes which will involve close
partnership work with Amy and transport
for greater Manchester and then the one
final thing that people have also picked
on this evening is getting those Basics
right and that is why we're proposing
multi-million pound investment in our
highways including resurfacing patching
attention to potholes and drainage
the journey towards setting a balanced
budget can be long complex and at times
a frustrating experience
however we're fortunate fortunate enough
to have highly skilled Finance officers
and a wider corporate leadership team
and a team of budget holders with vast
experience
we're also fortunate to have a strong
scrutiny function to provide that
important challenge as well as many
counselors who understand the challenges
of local government finance and I did
hear cross-party acknowledgment of that
point so I do want to recognize that
this budget helps set up Trafford for a
bright and exciting future and I'm proud
of the part we've all played to deliver
it thank you
the resolutions set out on the reports
have been moved and seconded I'll now
move to the vote and remind you that
statutory regulations require votes on
the budget to be recorded
please can those in favor show their
hands
thank you
and those against please
and are there any abstentions
thank you the motion is carried
we moved to item four on the agenda
director of Public Health I invite
councilor Slater the executive member
for health and wellbeing and equalities
to introduce and move the next item
concerning the recruitment for a
director of Public Health which was
recommended to council by the employment
committee on the 6th of February
councilor Slater thank you mayor
details a requirement for us to recruit
a new director of Public Health as the
current post holder has indicated her
intention to retire in May this year
as you know the dphd is a statutory post
and as set out in the Local Government
Act and Housing Act of 1989 and Health
and Social Care Act makes it clear that
each local Authority must actively join
with the secretary with the Secretary of
State appoints an individual to have
responsibility for the public health
function under the ACT known as the
Director of Public Health
I think we would all agree that this is
a key post for Trafford residents this
is an extremely important role and it
ensures that the health of our
population is at the heart of the
council's priorities so that our people
live good long and healthy lives
the post of dhp was instrumental in
supporting our responses and Recovery to
the recent covid pandemic and I want to
specially acknowledge the role of the
current post holder eleanorolf has
played in the in in leading this and
navigate she navigated us successfully
through the challenges we all face
during this time and I want to ensure
that our personal thanks are captured
and noted in the report and in the
council minutes
for her dedicated service and passion
that she has demonstrated in this role
in reviewing the post and the
information and the salary information
we have benchmarks with our Public
Health counterparts across greater
Manchester and found that we are the
lowest payers in the currently with the
current sorry with the current salary
starting point of 95 000 pounds so we
are proposing to uplift the thoroughly
salary
level to a figure of up to 105 000 to
attract and retain a suitable for
qualified and skilled person to take on
this role and rightly note that staff
should be paid the correct rate for the
job that they undertake for us
the recruitment process because it is a
joint post and with the Secretary of
State we are to be supported by the
faculty of Public Health and must be in
it which must be an external process we
have been liaising with them and an
indicative recruitment timetable is on
underway for um for the advertisement
period of three weeks which will close
on the 26th of February the advert will
state that the salary of up to 11 sorry
up to 105 000 pounds I was going to say
11 pound then up to 105 pound is pending
approval
stakehold stakeholder panels have been
set up for the 13th and 16th of March
and a final panel with members and the
faculty of Public Health is currently
scheduled for the 22nd of March the
regional director of Public Health Dr
Andrew Ferber will be involved in the
shortlisting and final panel with
members as a successful candidate must
meet all his requirements and he has
delegated authority on behalf of the
Secretary of State to confirm the
appointment
employment committee approved the uplift
of the salary level at its meeting on
the 6th of February and has recommended
that Council note their approval for the
recommendations that the council now use
a salary of 105 pound in recognition of
pay comparisons across greater
Manchester and note the recruitment
arrangements are in progress with the
faculty of Public Health thank you
thank you uh councilor Slater is that
seconded please seconded math thank you
councilor Ross leader do any members
wish to speak on this report
councilor Jerome Council of Blackburn
can that order councilor Jerome please
and councilor wetton
thank you chair I just wanted to quickly
say we absolutely support this report
and just wanted to um Echo the words of
the executive member on paying tribute
to Eleanor Roth she's been a brilliant
director of Public Health she's always
had time for green party councilors and
we've we've learned so much from from
her work and she's obviously led us
through the covert period as well which
um which must have been immensely
difficult so we just wanted to make our
our tributes public thank you thank you
for those comment counselor Jerome
councilor Miss Blackburn
thank you Mr Mayor as a member of the
covid-19
during the
the calendar Row for all that she did
for Trafford could could have just asked
for clarification on 3.1 with within the
budget
um and it's it's sort of details
um extra money is that is that to do
with
um
the extra allowance for for various
costs
would have would have been able to sort
of get
um confirmation on that
is that for this role yes it it will be
with on costs so pensions and then
obviously moving up the grade it might
be that we don't recruit somebody at 105
it may be that it's a lower body yes
thank you very much thank you and yes
obviously you know we do do support this
it's very important that we have an
effective director of Public Health to
you know to to to to guide us and and to
lead improved Health throughout the
borough thank you thank you councilor
Miss Blackburn councilor wetton
thank you Mr Mayor uh just really wanted
to associate myself with those uh
remarks about uh Eleanor Rowe
um she's a director of a formidable
director of Public Health and whoever we
get in place I'm sure Eleanor will be
will be missed uh her
I wasn't here for her work during the
pandemic
um but her work that I've seen
um in my time on the council is uh on a
path of Excellence at a pure accidents
and um she will she will certainly be
missed thank you thank you councilor
waiting for those remarks
out to us later
I personally learned a lot from her and
um
I think this post needs to be really
rated competitively and appropriately to
reflect the magnitude and influence of
the role within the cows thank you Matt
no thank you very much anybody else a
quick word perhaps not in which case the
report has been moved and seconded can
it be agreed please or would you like me
to put it to the vote can it be agreed I
thank you that is the end of the meeting
I thank you all for your attendance
extender General invitation to join me
in the Parlor for refreshment thank you
everybody and I hope you enjoy the rest
of the evening
I hope